police in Romania raiding the home of
controversial online influencer Andrew
Tate
inside the Villa rinbucharest they find
an arsenal of weapons
guns knives
and stacks of cash
Tate his brother and two Romanian
Nationals who've been under
investigation since April are arrested
on suspicion of human trafficking rape
and forming an organized crime group The
Matrix has attacked me verbal attacks
are what Tate is known for widely
regarded as one of the most famous
people online he's grown his profile
through misogynistic racist and
homophobic commentary
Andrew Tate's content has been reached
by tens of millions hundreds of millions
or on Tick Tock it seems billions of
views of content which we're then seeing
consumed by primarily young men and and
it's really really dangerous to see so
many young men consuming such extreme
misogynist content
this Behavior has meant he's banned from
multiple social media sites except
Twitter it could have been this recent
video posted in his war of words with
Greta tunberg which led to his arrest
the pizza boxes from a Romanian chain
perhaps alerting authorities to his
location
as they questioned him in custody bags
of evidence from his home came to Tate
has denied any wrongdoing in the past
he's declined to comment on these latest
allegations
it is proposed that the suspects be
placed into custody they did not make
any statements
Tate says he moved to Romania because he
liked being able to do what he wanted
and like to be free
Freedom which threatens to be
compromised
Ashton is